yeah which is why it's great when we get
like a production like freen which is a
[__] Banger anime and has had like me
to watch it it's so good it's it's also
I see a little porn of it is that why do
I see that on Twitter it's I I I noticed
this as well I I was going to talk about
this because I remember read I remember
reading the manga and it was like I
thought my Twitter feed was weird I
haven't seen any of that [__] it was it
was but I'm not surprised only the only
stuff I've seen a free is porn really
yeah which means that it's either like
an amazing amazing show or a dog okay so
so here's here's the weird thing okay so
um as like a manga reader fore end I'm
never reading the manga it's a very like
touching emotional show right and it's
its characters are definitely not like
let's say the fan service type okay okay
like a lot of like yeah you know all of
like basically all of the girls in there
uh you know they a very very I can't
think I can't even think of a scene
where they are like even showing a lot
of skin like a lot of clothes they wear
like cover all of their bodies can't
really see their proportions it doesn't
the the story and the vibe of the whole
show doesn't really incite any of that
kind of like mentality in any way story
of the vibe as well because it's they're
really [__] squeezing this [__] out
it's a very like emotional touching tail
so what freen has proved to me is that
it don't [__] matter about the vibe
at all if people want to lud someone
they the internet are going to [__]
do it all it takes is one artist to be
like this is a wholesome show but that
character's hot well it's like I I
didn't think the fish girl was hot in
Zelda but I saw a lot of porn of the
fish girl speaky yourself that's she was
hot okay I'm sorry I'm just being honest
I'm just being honest but like yeah it
is it is kind of a weird phenomenon
because we haven't really seen examples
of similar Vib like that's kind of like
people you know know looting Spice and
Wolf which no one really did because
this because well I mean I didn't see it
because like and it's because it's such
someone definitely looted [__] and wolf
I mean the only one who looted Spice and
Wolf was hakura himself for making Holo
just naked for a lot of the show that's
the thing you know what's weird
sometimes now I see if there was like a
fan servy show I never see any like lude
fan out of it right you know what I mean
now it's just like the anti-an servy
show Doan artists are like playing the
reverse yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
are they are and I feel like I don't
know I I I feel like with freen there
was this one scene in the latest episode
where I okay there was like one I think
horny bait scene but it was just like
compared to other horny bait scenes it
was like very very tame um it was when
free Ren like there was a shot where
free Ren had her feet just like
showing and artist are like yo it's free
real estate let's go show feet show feet
she showed her feet let's go let me see
her
feet why does people like feet so much
what the deal with feet I don't get it I
wish I wish I could understand isn't it
the most common fetish though in the
world or something uh don't know I think
I remember seeing something bustard oh
my
God don't put words in my
mouth I wish I got it I wish I got it
but I just so I could understand the
mind yeah I think I think I read
somewhere that like feet fetishes are
yeah I think Fe fetish is the most
common fetish it's it's called so the
technical term is called podofilia oh my
Lord they really they really shouldn't
have yeah yeah I'm a
pile oh he's a Potter yeah I can't
imagine that one caught on with the the
feed
enjoyers Naval fetishes body piercings
tattoos gerontofilia
uh underwear hair color oh the intense
sexual attraction that younger men and
women feel for older men and women can
qualify as a fe oh cradle snatching all
right oh
crad what the
[__] yeah feet is like the most common
yeah Feet's the most common yeah I don't
I don't get it I mean I'm personally not
into it but there could be worse things
you're into what kind is a
fetish get sexual if you get bricked up
yeah if you get bricked up so his boobs
a fetish well I think because it's like
no that's just an instinct but that's
that's the thing right what what counts
as a fetish I thinks boobs n ass could
technically be a fetish but they're so
common place that we wouldn't consider
is unusual yeah I think fetish is
something where the the the Layman would
look at it and be like I don't really
feel anything to but then there'll be
someone else that be like no that's hot
gratification is strongly linked to a
particular object or activity of a body
it needs to be something super specific
other than a sexual other than the
sexual organs so dis count as a fetish
yeah okay yeah that's that's a fetish
number two an in an inanimate object
woried for its supposed magic powers or
because it's considered to be inhabited
by a spirit I've never heard of this
definition of fetish I think I've I've
read that being used in that sense I was
very confused oh cuz I was like huh what
that's that's
weird but yeah uh I don't know why I
don't know why it is Freer Ren that all
the artists have chosen to uh I think
we've I think we've kind of grown up in
an age now where like when it comes to
the Doan community at least from how I
observe it as someone who's you know
followed it for a long time like when
you look back to like the 2000s or like
the 2010s right it was the obvious Doan
bait shows that would get the most Doan
right where it's the shows that were
either just straight up sexualizing the
characters in the original story or ones
that kind of alluded to sexualizing the
characters but didn't necessarily go all
the way through now I feel people again
have played the reverse game where it's
like they look at the obvious looted
stuff or the ones that allude to it and
they go no but that's too obvious the
show is already doing it for us so let's
take the ones where the show doesn't
even hint at it at all and give people
what they might possibly want that they
can't get from the original show and so
I think that's why shows like free Ren
now are getting more looted than other
looa shows cuz like we never saw any
doons of like readed off healer because
the show was already doing it for a lot
of people right like but free rent is
not is a [__] the characters [__] of
course I don't [__] feel anything but
you know that doesn't stop the fact that
there were a lot of people who watched
that show and were like well you know
the show is already going all the way
through so Doan artists were like well
there's no place for us they've already
done it for us whereas free is like they
look innocent but they are aesthetically
pleasing characters where if we put them
in lwd positions a lot of people might
like it I don't know that's just my
observation as a Doan uh professional I
think it's the implication you know yeah
it's it because I don't know it's it's
weird because I does it ruin the show I
don't think it does this isn't a
complaint this is not a complaint at all
this is this is merely just an
observation see I don't know because
like I think I mentioned this in an
earlier podcast episode but like I can't
read doans of shows I really enjoy oh
yeah you did mention that so like monari
couldn't be me monari like any of the
shows that I grew up with I can't read
doans of it cuz it just ruins my
perspective of the shows that I love so
much Pokémon
no
what speaking of fetish is there
something telling us the [__] did that
come from listen listen are you a furry
no no I just wanted to see how you'd
react look if you're into it cool but
that ain't me I'm not into it what about
vapore did you
know I'm just I'm just curious God OFA
okay no love bun no no no yeah um
chansy that would be an interesting one
oh my where did you
start oh we're go to
house what are we talking about I don't
know I just thought it was [__] dumb
but I just thought about it but see like
that's why like the doans I always
enjoyed reading were the shows that I
had no personal connection to or
affiliation to from the original show so
like I had no problems reading like Oro
dojin because I don't give a [__] about
the original show or the original
characters I don't care what position
they're put what you're saying is you
maybe you don't like the canonical
breaks that the Doan introduced it kind
of ruins the entire story I think so how
did you guys have you guys ever read I
guess dojan are kind of like fan
fictions never or kind of like fan kind
of like stories that have nothing to do
with let's say you know like hentai or
anything but just literally just like
let's say a fan story yeah do you enjoy
those at all have you ever had a point
where you're like damn the can story
didn't give me everything I wanted to
and uh I I kind of went into like the
fan territory no because I'm like cuz I
also understand that that was that
particular manga artist or you know
writer's decision to do so and you know
I might not be satisfied with it but you
know at the end of the day I can just
move on to something else as well you
know like I'm not I don't think I've
ever read a series where it's been that
I've been so heavily invested into where
I'm like I want to see the best ending
for the and this is the exact ending
that I Envision and I hope the artist or
writer delivers and then it be something
completely different usually like with
those kinds of stories I get heavily
invested into I'm satisfied with the way
it ends in some regard and if there are
ones where like I'm not satisfied with
it then I'm just going to go well you
know it wasn't exactly what I had hoped
for but I I still enjoy the ride and you
know I can just move on to something
else can you Google the most famous fan
stories i' I've love to know examples of
like what are some really popular fan
stories well wasn't like uh wasn't uh
what was it yeah 50 Shades of Gray right
50 Shades of Gray was a Twilight fan F
fan fiction yeah it's it's I've done it
twice I've I've I you've done it twice
what do you mean you've done it what do
you mean you've done it um in you've
written one no not written okay I was
about to say I guess no no no like
consumed like some fan some fanfiction
out of some dissatisfaction to like a
main like story line which ones are they
yeah could you click the article 10
successful books that yeah oh yeah yeah
let's let's check these out 50 Shade
yeah obviously cyia bones love
hypothesis I don't know any of
these okay I do not know any of these
either F girl okay yeah don't know that
don't know that I don't know any of well
here's the thing I don't think we're
like the usual kind of like I don't
read that was fair that's fair I
mentioned like this book I was reading
once on trash t I was nearly done with
it I had like I had like um not like 40
50 pages left in it yeah uh and I was
like yeah I'll talk about when I'm done
and I just never [__] finished it
this is like was it the Brad in Japan
book I I haven't started
yet but I was like man I I I think I
just don't enjoy reading as much as I I
wish I did a manga I enjoy but even then
I I think I just too much I don't really
enjoy reading that much I wish I did
that's fair I wish I wish I did cuz I
feel like why you wish you did because
it feels like such a a vast uh a vast
untapped source of knowledge and also
like the world you can throw yourself
into uh so much more imaginative novels
and stories and I wish I could kind of
get into it but sadly I can't yeah like
I was saying you like I there are two
things that like stick out to my mind in
terms like fanfiction Fanfictions I
guess the first one uh I remember being
first time watching Evangelion being
very very dissatisfied with the ending
right the TV seriesend the TV series
ending and the end of AA the ending as
well this is back in my point where I
like [__] hated AA right uh and I
remember discovering this Doan which I
think is like the greatest Doan of all
time that I've ever read it's called
retake okay where it's kind of like a
reimagining of the Evangelion ending
that kind of like ties in all all of the
plot points uh that cuz you know if
you've seen AA you know that there's a
different appeal to the end of evangelon
then
let's say tying up all the plot points
cuz half the plot points just [__]
they forget about you know uh but it
gives this was before like 4.0 came out
it gives you like it gave you like it
gave me emotional closure for all of the
characters which the original series
didn't do and do you think that's why
unno made 4.0 he's like I see all I see
people are very dissatisfied with the
ending I'm going to make my own fan
fiction of my own show I don't think ano
gives a [__] being honest I mean I feel
like I feel like the entire rebuild was
just his own fanfiction of it you pretty
much pretty much and I remember the
second time I did this as well was the
first time I'm reading Love
Hina where you're like but what if what
if what if what if other girls had like
a nice happy ending yeah uh and that was
the last time I ever dipped my feet into
the world of Fanfictions okay but to be
fair like there was one show there was
one manga series that I think did that
in a really really cool way uh and it
was this manga called uh book that b you
know like we can't study or we can't
something like that they had a canonical
like one of the girls like you know
getting the bag and you know that was
like the end of like that har but then
the author did a gigabrain move and he
released one more volume where he gave a
canonical ending to every single love
interest so that everybody would be
satisfied n boss phoned it in Bossman
phoned it in Boss phoned it in but he
also gave everybody a satisfying ending
in one way or another was like you know
what I will not I will not let the Doan
artist take the bag I'm doing this
myself godamn it uh we we we need one
winner in a harm anime or everyone's a
winner you know yeah what isuck
participation award har look it didn't
matter cuz my favorite girl won
canonically so I I was satisfied with
them but I was like said all them
account well technically they weren't
but he was just like this this was like
a what if scenario of like he picked the
other girls like he basically visual
noed it essentially that just sounds
like copium it's I was absolutely copium
but I would also be huffing that same
copium if I was him as well like I can't
believe you didn't pick this girl I I
feel like I would be less invested in
Haram anime if I knew every girl was uh
going to have a happy ending you know I
feel like to me the appeal of Haram
anime is knowing that one of these girls
is going like a football team you pick a
pick a side yeah Haram anime is just
like Sports Anime in Disguise it's it's
the closest that anime fans come to
being tox
sports fans yeah
basically yeah yeah 100% you know that's
why uh but at the same time you're also
calling out every fan fig riter as well
in that sense then f i I will happily
say that I was in copia mode where I was
just like I just want to see different I
I I just like give me a crumb give me a
crumb of cope right now because I being
like I just want to see Oscar happy
that's all I care about and I don't care
if I have to search through the Deep
crevices fanfiction.net to find that
[__] why the [__] did you have to call
me
out oh God I know you all I know not
need to be called out like that